[Music]
hey pal what's up come on man I just
took you out I really don't have to go
okay buddy
[Music]
John Carpenter's this thing welcome back
to another one of my favorite movies I
don't do these enough I need to do more
of these for you guys I get a lot of
requests to do more of this segment John
Carpenter's The Thing came out in 1982
and it starred Kurt Russell it was
technically a remake of the 1951 film
the thing from another world which was
based off of the book who goes there it
was a retelling of the tale about a
creature that is able to infiltrate any
living organism and after it mutates it
can imitate that organism perfectly
whether it's a human being or an animal
and these men are all stuck in
Antarctica at a research facility in
which none of them know who is who this
thing is taking over them one by one and
it becomes a game of wits to figure out
who is the thing and who is a human and
it's absolutely riveting the thing is
one of my favorite science fiction
monster movies of all time and not just
because it has some of the best
practical effects ever put to screen and
some of the coolest most frightening
moments you've ever seen in a horror
film this is actually a magnificently
well directed movie and not just because
John Carpenter is very good at composing
a beautiful shot one of the things that
I think is very underrated about this
film is the excellent use of editing and
timing because when you are trying to
build suspense in a film one of the best
ways to do that is to know exactly how
long to hold a shot how long to keep
your audience looking at the screen
knowing exactly how long or how short to
cut a shot is imperative to building
suspense and John Carpenter and his
editor knew that so well I said it
earlier but this film really does have
some of the best practical effects ever
created to this day they hold up I
watched the film last night in
preparation for this review I'm amazed
how good this film still looks all these
years later a lot of the actors on this
film have stated they were actually
getting sick to their stomach when they
saw some of these prosthetics and some
of these things that were created for
the movie because they just looked so
lifelike
and that created performances that you
cannot get from an actor who's staring
at something that doesn't exist a tennis
ball on a pole and later to put some CGI
in the movie these are performances you
can only get when these types of things
are right in front of you another thing
I did to help the actors in this movie
was they actually chilled the location
they were filming in to a 40-degree
level so it was similar to how it would
actually be in Antarctica that made the
actors look cold
they never look as if they're in a warm
nice studio room these guys are actually
suffering a little bit and that's why
the performances worked so well in this
movie when this film came out a lot of
people did not like this movie at all I
mean John Carpenter had already gotten
some recognition for his Halloween film
which by the way in Halloween the movie
the two kids are watching on the screen
is the original the thing from another
world that's a little bit of a fun fact
for you a lot of people did not like
this movie believe it or not they found
it too dark too gory they didn't like
the ending and unfortunately for John
Carpenter the maker of the original
thing from another world denounced this
remake as well it wasn't until later
where people start to really flock to
this movie and show it the appreciation
that it deserves one of the things I
love about this movie and that keeps the
suspense so incredibly real is the fact
that as you're watching the movie you
don't know who the thing is you never
know who the thing is until he shows
himself and an interesting tidbit the
actors as well as John Carpenter have
since stated in various interviews that
they didn't even know who the thing was
as they were filming the movie now
obviously when there's a big scene and
one of the actors is going to be the
creature for that scene they knew that
I'm talking about the fact that when
they were filming conversation scenes no
one was ever directed by saying you are
the creature right now that kept the
skepticism amongst the actors themselves
as well not just the audience another
terrific thing about the suspense
building of this movie is the use of the
location it feels incredibly confined
very claustrophobic there are great
movies like this with a bunch of Angry
Men in the location that's confined and
it really just works to build suspense
like 12 Angry Men for instance another
film in which a whole bunch of men are
stuck in a room and it just works in my
opinion Kurt Russell has never been
better than he was in this movie all of
the actors give such good performances
because you can feel that they are all
truly in that environment by doing
things like
making the location actually 40 degrees
inside by not telling them which one is
the thing by giving them all of these
great locations to work with as well as
the best dog performance of all time
strengthen everyone's performances to a
level way higher than your average
monster movie add John Carpenter's
terrific direction the editing the
prosthetics the music the thing is one
of the best horror films ever made and
if you guys have not checked this film
out I strongly suggest it it is one of
my all-time favorite movies and I'm
going to give the thing in a plus guys
thank you so much for all of your
awesome suggestions I will do my best to
review more of my favorite movies for
you guys in the future and as always if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mint iced
[Music]
you